if I was to go to Hong Kong I would look
for the most to just the the nature
that's nice yeah I didn't do that
so now that Hong Kong is open to
visitors again we want to take a quiz to
see how much we really know about it
hopefully something hopefully we'll find
out I guess how many total islands make
up Hong Kong
Hong Kong 300. Hong Kong
261. that's really close go back one and
add one Hong Kong 268
263.
let me go one more time no I wanted to
win okay oh I want to go island hopping
now true or false Hong Kong's famous egg
tart pastry is called dantat
I don't know what that's called
Hong Kong
true
Hong Kong I'm gonna say this is true
I've had a Don tap before it's really
good true or false most restaurants in
Hong Kong serve exclusively Cantonese
cuisine it's a pretty Multicultural
Place true I'm gonna say false correct
the answer is false while the city's
Cuisine is largely influenced by
Cantonese cuisine Hong Kong is home to a
wonderful assortment of restaurants
including Thai Indian and even Nordic
true or false Shang Wan is one of the
hippest places in Hong Kong for food
drinks shopping and nightlife Hong Kong
true feels true it's like has a hip name
it's home to hip coffee shops cute
shopping boutiques and a great place to
pick up antiques
100 bringing an extra suitcase oh I love
the good Thrift take all my money true
or false does Hong Kong have over a
hundred official hiking trails Hong Kong
that was me I'm gonna say true and I
hope I'm right because I love hiking and
if I can hike in Hong Kong that's only
gonna be a plus pretty sure
that's correct
Hong Kong true there's around 130
official hiking trails and even more
unofficial hiking trails the longest is
over a hundred kilometers running
through eight country Parks it's a long
walk that's a long walk in Hong Kong how
many Michelin starred restaurants are
there
uh
uh 65. Hong Kong 84.
70. Hong Kong 71 the correct answer is
78. that's unbelievable where else in
the world can you get that how many
temples can you find in Hong Kong
Hong Kong I'm going to say over 300
because it's a very big place that's
correct true or false because Hong Kong
is a large Metropolitan region you need
to get on a flight to experience some of
its most stunning hiking trails
Hong Kong yeah that's that's got to be
true that's false some of the city's
outlying Islands can be reached within
an hour
you ready to go book those tickets I
think that's exactly what we need to be
doing all right perfect let's go to Hong
Kong
[Music]
okay fix it in post exactly
I'd love to hear that all right